[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily attorneys for scott
peterson are back in court
why the convicted killer is preparing
for a new trial if you play it out
there's no way they convict him
the so-called black widower gets his
conviction thrown out from murdering his
wife
and the man he's accused of hiring to
kill her how many other people are on
death row and get a shot at another
trial
plus iowa farmers face off in the
state's supreme court
the civil case over a deadly shooting
jason was liable for killing his mother
and we break down police body cam
footage of a man killed in front of his
own home
why his family is calling for mental
health reform law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
convicted wife killer scott peterson
will have to wait a little bit longer
to hear when he'll get a new sentence
peterson was found guilty of murdering
his wife lacey and their unborn child
conor
on christmas eve 2002. investigators say
peterson dumped lacey's body
into the san francisco bay where it
later washed up he was sentenced to
death
but the state's highest court overturned
his penalty saying prospective jurors
were improperly dismissed at trial
peterson's trial attorney insists he's
innocent i mean people can talk about
he's guilty he's guilty he's guilty the
fact is nobody knew
knows or knew that evidence better than
our team did in real time
and there wasn't a single person on the
team who didn't feel as if
there was a complete collapse of any
evidence by the way
including the trial judge at various
times during this case
the california supreme court is also
ordering a san mateo county judge
to determine if peterson could get a new
trial in this separate appeal
the high court found a juror committed
prejudicial misconduct by not disclosing
that she was a victim of a crime
there is no to my mind justice that has
been for lacey
for scott for conor or for either of the
families
peterson appeared via zoom for a status
check on his case he's being held in san
quentin state prison
peterson waived his right to a speedy
trial he's due back in court
april 27th joining me now is criminal
defense attorney julie rendellman along
with terry austin
julie presidential misconduct could be
the reason peterson gets a new trial
do you agree with the judge here though
oh absolutely
you know keep in mind we have two things
going on we have the sentencing where
he's getting a new
sentence and now we potentially have a
new trial you have basically a juror
that lied about the fact that she had
she was the victim of something and that
she was involved in
in a civil you know issue with regards
to an order of protection which kind of
goes to the heart of this specific case
um particularly lacie being pregnant so
it's shocking um that obviously she
didn't reveal it and i think that it's
a huge issue particularly when it comes
to this jury making determination
not just about guilt but about the death
penalty absolutely it wasn't just that
she was a victim but the facts of her
case were very close to that of scott
peterson
terry even if there is prejudicial to
misconduct
that doesn't guarantee a new trial why
and do you think
there should be a new one you know i
agree with julie here there should be a
new trial as much as
i want to see him convicted because i do
think that the evidence points directly
at him
he is entitled as all defendants are to
due process and if there was
during misconduct then in fact the you
know
verdict should be overturned and they
should get an opportunity for a new
child one thing i will say brian
if in fact we have a new trial the
prosecution is
really going to have to make sure that
the jury is selected property that it's
an unbiased jury
and that the evidence that goes in
cannot be
the cause to overturn yet another
verdict
yeah and this is a situation terry just
as a follow-up where it's
not the evidence that was presented but
merely the fact that one person should
not have been there
so will we likely see a same trial and
potentially a same verdict
if this case does go to trial again i
think they're going to put in all the
same evidence brian but i think that
they're going to be
very careful in jury selection and make
sure they don't have someone who
is potentially going to have the case at
the end of the day
overturned like we had here that is a
distinct
possibility of course no matter whether
you're guilty or innocent you still
have to have an unbiased jury to
evaluate that evidence against you
otherwise this system that we have and
we love so much doesn't really work
thank you both turning now to other top
news terry austin has an update to the
capitol riot
yeah brian the capitol police officer
recognized for his bravery
during the insurrection was tasked with
another very important duty
escorting the vice president-elect to be
sworn in
officer eugene goodman walked vice
president kamala harris
to the inauguration ceremony he was
promoted after the riots
and is now acting deputy senate sergeant
at arms
goodman was seen on january 6 being
chased up the capitol stairs by a mob
he then tricked the riders into
following him away from the open senate
chamber
to a hallway where more officers were
waiting
a pennsylvania woman accused of stealing
a laptop from house speaker nancy
pelosi's office has been released from
jail
a federal judge ruled riley june
williams could be released into the
custody of her mother and must appear in
court in washington d.c
on monday williams is charged with theft
obstruction
trespassing violent entry and disorderly
conduct on capitol grounds
according to the fbi a former romantic
partner of williams
tipped him off that she claimed she
hoped to sell the computer to russian
intelligence
williams defense lawyer told the judge
that his accusations
are overstated still ahead on law and
crime daily a farm family torn apart by
murder
heads back to court but first why a
conviction and sentence for a man found
guilty of killing his wife
and a hitman is being thrown out the
latest twist in the bizarre case
after the break
[Music]
a man convicted of hiring a hitman to
murder one of his six wives in las vegas
is getting a new trial anjanet levy has
more in the case
and an interview with the creators of a
new podcast that have exclusive
interviews with the defendant
yeah brian thomas randolph was sentenced
to death for the 2008 murder of his wife
sharon
he says he is stone cold innocent the
killer jeans
podcast is brand new and it takes a deep
dive into the case
my wife's been shot and there's a guy in
my house and i shot him
prosecutors say that 9-1-1 call was
staged and that thomas randolph
paid a hit man to kill his wife sharon
in 2008 to collect life insurance money
and then killed the hitman randolph's
been talking to melissa mccarty and
kelly mclear
creators of the killer jeans podcast
i've been talking to this man for
three years and he has never wavered in
his stance that he is an
innocent man and we're not here to say
whether he's guilty or innocent
but it is someone that prosecutors are
calling a socio and psychopath
randolph has been dubbed the black
widower he's been married
six times four of his wives are dead
including becky
who died in utah in 1986. randolph was
acquitted of her murder
prosecutors discussed that at his trial
for sharon's murder
and that's why he's getting a new trial
is thomas randolph just a guy who is
completely unlucky in his love and his
marriages and just
seems to always be in the wrong place at
the wrong time
or is this man a genuine serial killer
in a
psycho and sociopath
and that's the question these podcasters
are trying to answer
i contacted the clark county district
attorney's office for
an interview my request for that
interview was declined and i was also
told
there would be no comment thomas
randolph is going to be in a nevada
courtroom later this week
brian as i understand it this is a
two-part podcast
so thomas randolph had a lot to say
yeah that was the interesting part of
this interview they said that he had a
lot to say
all of the time he talked to them quite
a bit and it was very unfiltered they
said he has an
answer for everything and he actually
admitted to being a serial cheater
but he says he is not a wife killer so
that part was very interesting
and i should mention that randolph's uh
daughter actually told the podcasters
that she is very glad that her father is
getting a new trial
but sharon randolph's daughter said that
she believes he is guilty
and that she will be in the courtroom
each day of that new trial
thanks for the update angenette our
panel is back with us for legal analysis
terry serial cheater but not serial
uh wife killer or wife killer as he says
what do you make of the court reversing
the conviction
you know again i'm going to say due
process is due process
and you know under both federal law and
nevada state law
if you have evidence of a prior crime it
cannot be
admitted to show propensity or character
evidence
and so what they needed to do here was
to show that
it was something to do with the motive
or intent and that way it may have been
admitted so i think that you know this
is one of those cases where even if you
believe that the individual was guilty
you just have to make sure that you are
introducing
evidence properly and that because you
failed to do that the case won't be
overturned absolutely
now julie the conviction is overturned
and a potential trial is on the horizon
do you think the defense has a chance
now that the prosecution might not be
able to use
one of the wife's deaths as evidence
sure i mean i i think they have a chance
obviously it's going to be a an uphill
battle because you know they had
basically the jury not just considering
one murder but they were considering
two murders and one of the things that
stuck out when there was a reversal was
the fact that the first trial
resulted in an acquittal so they were
like why are we bringing in evidence
from a case in which there was acquittal
which brings back the durst case because
that's coming up too that we're
following and in that case they're
allowing in an old case where there was
an acquittal and so it's interesting
what the appellate issues could be with
durst
and they may be very similar to what
happened here yeah if you're acquitted
how can you bring that back up in a
trial you're being prosecuted for
and jeanette what do you expect of
randolph's upcoming hearing to be about
yeah this is really going to be the
first hearing in this
new kind of phase of the retrial so this
is going to be a lot of housekeeping
issues
he doesn't have a lawyer right now he
had an appellate lawyer but now he is
going to have to have a
new trial lawyer appointed for him by
the court
likely going to be a public defender and
there will likely also be some
scheduling issues taking place for
future proceedings and we also found out
that
he has been ordered by the judge to
appear in person he can't
really appear in person per se but they
are transporting him and he will
appear via video conference for that
hearing in clark county
all right so it's probably going to be a
lot of moving pieces before we even get
to
any resemblance of a trial or a hearing
of course because you have a sign of a
public defender or some sort of council
and obviously we've got coven 19 honor
as well
thank you everyone for the update coming
up on law and crime daily prosecutors in
the george floyd case
lose their emotion for a second time
plus
should a civil judgment for a man
acquitted of murder be thrown out
or expert analysis ahead
[Music]
a father and son are going head-to-head
in the iowa supreme court over a 10
million dollar judgment
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross explains why a murder on the farm
is behind this civil case this is a
family tragedy
jason carter accused by his father bill
carter
of murdering his mother shirley carter
in 2015.
jason carter was found not guilty in a
criminal trial but he was found guilty
in a civil trial
now his lawyers will ask for a new trial
for the iowa supreme
court arguing on the other side will be
bill carter's lawyer mark weinhardt
he told me that he is confident the
court will turn down this request
bill is firmly convinced that jason
killed shirley which has to be one of
the most shocking
and troubling things that a father could
ever conclude
about his own offspring and yet bill
came to that conclusion based on the
evidence
and essentially the information is that
there are other people and other people
with criminal records in the community
who were possible suspects there were
tips about them
uh investigators say they ran down all
those leads and not determined that
anybody else
was responsible for the murder other
than jason
i'll fight this to the better end um
there's no doubt about that
there the until this is overturned or
something's done different
um just have to keep on putting up a
huge fight
it's a sad situation a farm family torn
apart by this murder
jason carter maintains if he gets given
a new trial he's ready for it he said
bring it on thanks brian back with me
are
our illegal experts julie rendellman and
terry austin
terry criminal trials have a higher
burden than civil so it makes sense that
you could be acquitted
of a criminal case but not a civil but
here we're talking about a potential
appeal
do you think that the fact that they won
the criminal case they could strengthen
old arguments in any potential civil
case
well you know it's really strange here
i've never seen anything like this i
mean it's a wrongful death action and
that's how they got the verdict in the
civil case
and the judge actually said that you
know previously
the result of the criminal trial doesn't
make the civil jury's findings
invalid and so you know it's two
separate standards of proof it's two
different
cases obviously one jury decided that in
fact
it was the son and he owed the money and
the you know criminal will have to see
what happens there but
it should not one affect the other so
we'll see what happens with the criminal
yeah julie and we've seen this before
when you see like officers
shooting individuals the civil case they
may win for example brianna taylor
and their criminal charges don't follow
so is it kind of the same thing here
where we're looking at this case and
saying
i'm not sure if there's gonna be a
stronger appeal in the civil case or am
i getting this completely wrong
so look i mean you know as you know as
terry said
the civil case happened first in the
civil case they found him liable and
that was a preponderance of the evidence
the criminal case happened second
and they determined that he was not
responsible based on beyond a reasonable
doubt
the position of the defense is wait a
second a we shouldn't have had to do
this civil case first
because we should have waited until we
got all the evidence
in the criminal case in order to you
know be able to better strengthen our
arguments in the civil case
and b that there was information from
the you know the
the the prosecution that wasn't provided
to the civil attorneys for jason carter
that prejudiced them during that case
i'm not so sure at the end of the day
the judges are going to you know give
him another shot at this
but certainly you know there were some
arguments made during the appellate
hearing
that seemed to potentially favor the
defense in terms of certain evidence
that they should have had a hold of
during that civil proceeding now julie
if you're a gambling person based on
what you saw in that hearing
do you think this lends itself towards
jason carter or against him
based on the arguments you heard you
know during
you know when uh jason carter's
attorneys were talking i was like hmm
i think that they're gonna go with him
and then all of a sudden i switched
because then we heard from
bill carter the father's attorneys and
they were asking him poignant questions
he was having difficulty answering some
of them so i'm really in the middle i
hate not being able to make a decision
but
i i i think it's going to be hard for
them to overturn it but i think there's
an
opening for that to happen all right
we'll see if we'll be able to make that
opening for it to happen thank you both
julie and terry
when we come back the police body cam
video of a deadly shooting in texas
why the victim's family is calling for
justice next
[Music]
a judge has yet again denied a motion to
delay the trial of one of the ex-cops
charged with murdering george floyd
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin is scheduled to go to trial in
march
minnesota judge peter cahill orders show
and be tried separately and before the
three other ex-cops
prosecutors had asked the judge to
reconsider that decision and for the
trials to be rejoined
judge calhill didn't provide a reason
for the denial but previously said that
other jury trials in hennepin county
are underway jury selection is slated
for march 8th
tune in to law and crime network for
capital gavel coverage
police in texas have released body cam
video showing the deadly shooting of a
man in front of his own home
patrick warren's family reportedly
called on january 10
asking for a mental health officer but
was told one was not available
clean police video shows killing police
officer reynaldo contreras
arriving to warren's home is the door
open
[Music]
the officer sees warren inside who is
gesturing for him to come in further
[Music]
the officer then goes outside and calls
for backup
no no no no no no no no no no no no i'm
gonna walk back out i don't work like
this
about 90 seconds later warren comes
outside
let me see your hands let me see your
hands warren moves towards the officer
who then fires his taser
one taste one taste lay down on your
back
lay down on the back warren pulls out
the taser prong
and goes towards the officer lay back
i'm gonna shoot you
i'm gonna shoot you the officer fires
three times
warren later died at a local hospital
officer contrails
is now on administrative leave warren's
families say they had also called the
day before
asking for a mental health deputy
because they believed he was having a
manic attack
an attorney for the family previously
released ring doorbell and cell phone
video
of the incident they're now calling for
the officer to be fired
terry and julie there are far too many
shootings on our black men
and every one i watch takes a little bit
more out of me this one did the same but
for
a different reason julie i see strong
arguments
for the officer that could amount to an
acquittal for him
and the our father that you can hear in
the audio after the shooting
would be a reason a lot of jurors would
have quit how do you see this
case fairing in the grand jury though
so i don't think this case is going to
the grand jury i'll be honest i don't
see it heading that
direction i think the problem we see
here when we talk about shootings
there's you know different things happen
in different cases in this case
i don't think it's the actions of the
officer that's the problem it's the
actions of the fact that the police
department can't provide what they're
supposed to provide
which is a mental health deputy now i
can't promise you
if a mental health deputy had come out
there and had
studied and known how to deal with
mental health issues
for a thousand years that the result
would have been different but at least
we would have had a shot at it being
different
and to me it's not this officer that did
anything wrong i think the officer
really did try to do everything right
de-escalate walk out tell him exactly
what he's going to do i'm not sure he
has options
when someone is running towards him with
the potential of a gun being taken
but i wish that there had been another
option and a mental health officer would
have come
perhaps we'd have a different result and
terry i tend to agree with julie there
and i think
a lot of uh the focus is there not on
the officer
and so i'm still asking and i'm really
angry the fact that we keep putting
officers who are armed in these
situations who have minimal if no mental
health training
because death is far too common the
result this
to me screams civil rights suit all over
it would you agree
oh absolutely in fact if there is no
grand jury and there is no
indictment or if there is an indictment
and there is a subsequent acquittal
which i agree with julie i think there
would be an acquittal if in case the
case goes forward
but i think the real solution here is
what you said brian we
absolutely need training as far as these
officers are concerned
and we need mental health professionals
responding
to these types of incidents and frankly
yes a civil suit should be brought here
and i know that there have been some
discussions about a civil suit
and that is what in fact the family
should do exactly we'll
be sure to monitor both the criminal and
potential civil cases
julian terry thank you very much for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here at long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you